paleontology a science geared towards
small children focused on digging up
dinosaurs while supporting a Jurassic
Park costume skulls are popped out of
the ground and put on display for public
gawking the relevance of this via and
clickbait coloring books and monster
movies is unknown no wait that's not
pathology at all paleontology is nothing
less than the study of past life all
past life from ancestors to alien forms
it involves fundamental questions like
who are we and how did we get here using
the broadest possible definition of we
life itself dinosaurs a category of
birds are just a small percentage of
that yet they get the most media
attention it's a very accurate meme okay
I didn't even make this one this is just
the truth anyway
most of us paleontologists consider
dinosaurs to be a gateway drug there is
so much cooler stuff in the fossil
record and we know so much about it
let's go out a brief dinosaur free tour
of the last four billion years first up
genetic material viruses basically
started producing proteins and wrecking
their environment the earth was infected
with life some of these new bacteria
learned how to eat sunshine producing
oxygen pulling in carbon from the air
and destroying the iron food of other
microbes by turning it into rust this
went on for billions of years
some bacteria consumed other bacteria
gaining their power to turn oxygen into
energy becoming the precursors of
animals and plants but as a result there
were climate shocks from hot to cold and
back again which ended up turning the
earth into a snowball
covered with glaciers the technical term
for this time period is snowball earth
700 800 million years ago
anyway microbes banded together creating
multicellular life 600 million years ago
geometric colonies appeared sucking
microbes from the water
these were soon replaced by the
ancestors of modern animals the Cambrian
explosion lobster relatives ate other
animals capturing them using their
grasping arms armored wriggling clam
worms crawled across the sea floor and
into it creating new ecosystems our
tadpole-like
ancestors flitted along ancient
coastlines while they're ill like
relatives with gnashing throat teeth
swam above the ice cream cone corals of
the first reefs dodging school bus sized
Krakens and hungry sea scorpions plant
fungus came onto land but then the
glaciers returned killing pretty much
everything but mass extinctions open
opportunities jealous fishes invaded the
ocean sporting points prawns and finally
Finn's
spiders scorpions snails and worms came
on to land somewhere around China a fish
developed jaws and it's descendants
drove jawless fishes sea scorpions and
ranching plankton to extinction some of
these fishes which had arm bones in
their fins sprouted fingers seven or
eight per flipper on land plants became
trees growing massive or spreading their
spores only once before dying
but then the glaciers came back again
and it was mass extinction number two it
was the age of weird fishes and plaited
sea lilies sharks with wings sharks with
buzzsaw jaws sharks with fins covered in
tiny teeth sharks with crushing tooth
plates bony fishes that looked like Badr
and angelfish and eels for the first
time
wetlands developed sporting ten-foot
long millipedes and giant dragonflies
these spread across the
per continent of Pangaea and died
creating coal leading to a hundred
million year ice age
finally vertebrates made it on to land
on a permanent basis
leading to alligator-like amphibians and
saber-tooth proto mammals but then
volcanoes erupted all over Siberia
everything almost died and it was mass
extinction number three the day life
nearly died a single lonely tusk mammal
survived and thrived but it was soon
replaced by galloping crocodiles in the
ocean marine reptiles giant rafts made
of the living relatives of sea urchins
and armored squids a monoids of every
kind in form but then Pangaea started to
split apart forming a sea of lava that
would one day become the Atlantic Ocean
spewing toxic gas into the atmosphere
and mass extinction number four yeah
there's actually a lot more than these
five these are the big ones so finally
there were whale sized fishes and modern
fishes mobbed corals made gigantic by
using their captured algae to eat
sunshine crabs stingrays and other
fishes with crushing teeth appeared
smashing shells and leading to an arms
race between predators and prey there
was an explosion of marine biodiversity
mammals climb trees flew and did a lot
of other things that are seemingly sort
of moderate they were feeding on the
first flowers pollinated by the first
bees there were ecological revolutions
on land and at sea leading to the modern
world except that an asteroid hit Mexico
and then that triggered volcanoes on the
other side of the world in India and
everything almost died again but there's
always a but because we're still here
mammals arose from the ashes became
small under extreme heat and that
ever-larger there
palm trees and snakes in the Arctic
predatory deer dogs frolicked along
ancient rivers while their relatives
returned to the ocean to become the
first outer like whales not hyenas and
other sort of carnivores were chased off
by giant blonde net rhinos everything at
this point seems kind of familiar but
not really in Antarctica an ice age
started forming the first permanent
polar icecap in 200 million years this
dried out the rest of the world but it
allowed the rise of grasses of rodents
of cats somewhere in Africa and apes
started walking across the new savanna
oh and there were a giant saber-toothed
salmon I just have to mention that so we
know all of this happened and so much
more how why paleontology is a thriving
science at the intersection of multiple
other fields and technologies there is
no bigger data than the fossil record
and we mind every bit of it we use cat
scans we use isotopes we use genomes we
use robots we use mathematical
simulations and all kinds of analytics
we maximize all of it so that we can
understand the past and how evolution
works
it also lets us make predictions for the
future what will happen after the next
mass extinction
what weird things will show up well
mammals get smaller again will there
even be mammals in some we have learned
a lot about dinosaurs but there's so
much left to learn from the other 99.9%
of things that have ever lived and
that's paleontology thank you
[Applause]